this man needs no introduction ESPN's
fantasy sports analyst mr. Matthew berry
how are you my friend what's up brother
didn't talk to you Matthew I talked to
you the other day we were at Gillette
doing an event you said you were working
around the clock how busy is it this
time of year for you it's you know
August is always sort of like my biggest
month obviously as everyone gets ready
for fantasy drafts we just launched a
new show on it yes yeah and called the
fantasy show it's on every day Monday
through Friday 5:00 p.m. Eastern on
espn2 and you can watch it online as
well yes Pam calm and our YouTube
channel and everything like that so it's
sort of everything I do
Plus this show so it's been it's been
the busiest artists of my life but you
know it's great it's just a testament to
how big fantasy football has become and
sort of the commitment that ESPN has to
it
how is it going how is the new show
going for you like who are you getting
uh are you are you getting uh the groove
yeah yeah it's fun it's it's you know
we're trying some different things which
is cool are our sort of mandate from the
bosses was it can't look like anything
else on ESPN so we we really took that
to heart so we're we're trying a bunch
of different things and you know if
there's some comedy and there's also
like a bunch of different you know
players that we're talking about a lot
of interesting stats you know we talked
about players that don't get mentioned a
lot on ESPN you know we talk about sort
of you know yesterday the other day we
talked about Xavier is a Jones George
kid all the tight end of in San
Francisco but you know like no one on
ESPN's talking about de Jones the the
Buffalo Bills white rook you wide
receiver or George kettle or Austin
Hooper or you know so it's been a lot of
fun doing all that well when you bring
up rookies who's going to be the fantasy
football Rookie of the Year I think
there's a couple of choices not to dodge
the question but this is as good a year
for rookies at least as far as running
back goes running backs go as I can
remember so you know the obvious guys
Leonard fournette and Jacksonville I
think he's going to have a monster here
they want to just do nothing but run the
ball they'll be ready by week one Chris
McCaffrey
report you here out of Carolina is just
raved and he's gonna run between the
tackles I think people thought coming
out of college maybe he'd be a little
bit too small for the pros he'd be more
of a gadget guy know Carolina's gonna
run it between the tackles in addition
to all the gadget stuff the short passes
and everything like that so McCaffrey
Joe mix it has a world of talent there's
an opportunity there you know I'm very
high on Kareem hunt the rookie in Kansas
City currently behind Spence aware but
he continues to Wow and the preseason we
saw what Alvin camara could do in New
Orleans rookie running back third down
back for them but you know Peterson and
Ingram have struggled with injury
concerns and them Dalvin cook continues
to dazzle in Minnesota so there's it's a
very exciting time for rookie running
backs and and finally Marlin back Marlin
Mac in Indianapolis again with with gore
in his age 34 season you don't expect
him to carry as much of a workload as he
has in the past I think you see some
Marlin Mac in there as well so it's it's
uh those are all guys that I like a lot
are you you always put up your your love
and hate column let's act like no one's
listening except for you and me and I
want you to give me just me your fellow
senior fantasy football analysts give me
a piece give me a little give me a
diamond in a rough who do you love the
most and who do you hate the most and I
use the word hate in a you know in a
fantasy term right in terms of their in
terms of their ADP it's always it's like
where they're going in dressed will give
me a position let's narrow it down a
little bit okay let's say running back
who do you love the most who's you know
it's 2017 it's hard to say anybody's a
sleeper but who is the guy that you
would say this is the guy that the the
the the the least discussed guy well I
don't know that Kareem hunt is the least
discussed guy who I just mentioned but I
really like him a lot he's currently
going is running back 40 on on espn.com
I'll give you another guy that I think
is undervalued he was going as running
back 31 I've been talking up for a while
some other people have as well so I
think as a starter ride but still I
think Adrian Peterson is going between
running back 25 and 31 and people like
you know Adrian Peterson we've been
talking about him forever and the
healthy was going on in the Saints of
Mark Ingram there but there's almost 300
running back touches that weren't Mark
Ingram last year there's like you know
like 246
and and this is a team that had 17
rushing touchdowns last year that over
the last three years has had the fourth
most rushing touchdown danfa we always
think the Saints is passing often but
they like to run when they get in closer
to the team that's highly efficient in
terms of their scoring and they run as
well I think there's a very good chance
that Adrian Peterson falls into
double-digit touchdowns this year I mean
you know he think about how many years
he was in Minnesota Michael where he had
to face all those eight-man front
you're not putting an eight-man front
against Drew Brees you'll get you know
you'll get killed
so I think he's gonna find very open
running lanes and given how good he is
around the goal line I for Adrian
Peterson to greatly out produce is a DP
all right that's good stuff and then as
far as running backs who is one person I
don't like this word hate but to stay
away from who's one person who's whose
stock shouldn't be as high as it is well
you know Spencer where is you know
Spencer where's the gunner that I
mentioned Kansas City one of the reasons
that I like cream hunt so much it's not
just his particular talent but if you
look a little bit closer at Spencer
where in terms of what he did last year
after carry 10 he averaged 3.3 yards per
carry
like he really wore down and it seems
like he's more suited for you know a
specialist role if you will less of a
workload than being a true workhorse
running back I think Kansas City
realizes that that he was just less
effective after 10 carry he had no
touchdowns last year after 10 carries so
my expectation is he's being drafted as
a starter or at least as a high-end flex
and I don't think he matches that might
my expectation is that at the end of the
year cream hunt has more fantasy points
than Spencer we're all right and then
Tom Brady you know a lot of people are
discussing picking him in the third
round when is it too early what round is
it too early to go after Tom Brady you
know what I probably wouldn't take Brady
until the 4th of the fifth he's gonna
have an insane year he's just gonna have
a monster year and you know it depends
on your league setting maybe you go a
little bit earlier if you're in a league
like Michael the one you and I played in
last year which was six points per
touchdown pass but in a general in a
standard League and ESPN standard League
for example there's only four points per
touchdown pass I'm waiting to the fourth
fifth even later you can wait on a
quarterback that's so deep and it's
as I think Brady or Rogers is they're
gonna have they're going in the second
round and that's too early for me like
Anna ten teen one quarterback League
there's all these kinds of leagues
there's you know auction there's you
know PPR nom people what is your
favorite type of League or or scoring
format like what do you think is the
most sort of fun for everybody you know
for every like it's all over the place I
don't really have an answer because I
love all forms of fantasy like you know
among my favorite leagues is like so I
play in a league with my wife and my kid
and we just do six points across the
board standard scoring because I wanted
to keep it really simple because we've
got like some 10 and 11 year-olds in
there right but I also played a 16 team
PPR League you know with a bunch of
people at ESPN and I love that League
it's super competitive you got to really
dig deep you know standard ESPN leagues
or ten team PPR I love PPR so I don't
really actually have a a favorite I do
enjoy two quarterback leagues as well
now when you're in these competitive
leagues with when it's all sort of you
know the highest of the high brow
fantasy and NFL people like how come I
mean that just seems like the best of
the best and the most fun like how can
how competitive does it get its insanely
competitive because it's you know here
the the league I'm referring to here at
ESPN it's like so it's it's it's Trey
Wingo it's Adam Schefter it's more Trent
Dilfer in the league you know so it's
it's all these people that you've seen
on television for many years filled you
a chance to find you about my co-host on
the podcast they're in it as well so
it's it's just a bunch of people that
know the NFL really well that have tons
of contacts
I played Adam Schefter in the in the
playoffs last year and he got he got a
tip the night before from an assistant
on Atlanta that he should start Tevin
Coleman hmm Kevin Cole this is the game
against the ran Tevin Coleman gets to
give me touchdowns from inside the five
he had three all year but two of them
came against me instead of Devon Taha
Tevin Coleman had the huge year you know
and so Adam hadn't really been starting
to heaven Coleman you know ended up
beating me and that was the difference
like how do you compete against that I
remember another time a Trent Dilfer and
I were talking about a tray
and I was going to trade him a wide
receiver he's gonna give me a running
back back so we'd agreed on the trade
and then later that afternoon I sent him
the official trade you know through the
website and he rejected it and so I
texted Trent I'm like what's going on I
thought we had a deal he's like yeah
sorry I texted his quarterback he don't
like him like so I won't say the
quarterback is but I mean just like
literally that's the kind of league
where like Trent Dilfer could literally
text an NFL quarterback and say what do
you think about this guy I'm thinking
about trading him for fantasy and the
quarterbacks like yeah don't do it I
don't like that guy I like that kind of
listen if you want to give me some
emails and you need me to send some
anonymous things to shake it up or get
people unfocused you know I'm your guy
Messi upgrader there is no greater trash
talker than Michael Rapaport I can
attest at that just if you need anybody
to get you know like anybody needs I'm
straightening out just send me the names
you know and you know you have the
anonymous email chain for me
Matthew finally levy on bail does this
stock drop because he's missed the
entire training camp or is he is he
still your number to pick he's my number
to pick but I wouldn't I wouldn't be
lying if I said you know I feel totally
fine with it oh we did something
actually on the show today they'll be
coming out later on the fantasy show but
we looked at it and you know Jamal
Charles I'm sorry not Jamal Charles
larry johnson chris johnson and maurice
jones-drew all the fantasy superstars
all held out and in the three years for
taking their average of the three years
prior to the year they held out they
averaged 28% less fantasy points per
game and their holdout year than they
did in the previous three years and you
know and and Larry Johnson and Maurice
jones-drew both also missed significant
time hmm am I saying that is that could
definitely happen the lady on bail no
but somebody who has had injury concerns
as well he hasn't been in camp you hope
he's keeping in shape you assume he's
keeping achievement
he hasn't been part of their workout
regimen it just makes you a little
nervous it's why I have David Duncan as
a clear-cut number one and lady on bail
still my number two but I will say that
I do think James Connor who's basically
don't unwrap it and who I would expect
to be lay beyond Belle's back up
something were to ever happen to him is
somebody that is absolutely you should
grab it
end of your draft you can't because
we've seen what the Angela Williams can
do we've seen what the number two
running back even Fitzgerald who saw it
when he's got a shot whoever the running
back is in Pittsburgh that offense is so
efficient and runs so well whoever it is
is gonna have value
all right well Matthew I appreciate the
information I appreciate the insight the
name of the show is the fantasy show
it's on ESPN I toasted by the great
Matthew Barry I appreciate the time
Matthew and good luck and get get some
sleep when you can and like I said if
you ever need me they will rattle the
cage for anybody over there you know
where to find me
absolutely Michael thanks man I talk to
you soon the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy